our country should be more fearful
of of white man hey guys I'm off the
grid for August but noted racist
anti-semitic communist socialist awful
human being ilhan Omar did this there's
been an explosion in the number of
anti-muslim far-right white nationalist
groups in the U.S over the past couple
of years your own state of Minnesota
experienced a record number of
anti-muslim incidents in 2016.
um you yourself I believe just a few
weeks after election Victory I think you
had a cab driver called you filthy and
Isis and threatened to remove your hijab
how much do you hold Trump and the rise
of trump responsible for this explosion
of U.S islamophobia
oh I would actually come very short of
of holding them exclusively responsible
um for for the rights I think when you
demonize
um and dehumanize it is easy for people
to to to to commit acts of violence
against those those individuals because
they no longer see them as as a person
as someone who who has feelings who's
worthy of respect and I think that is
where we are moving away from the idea
that we we are supposed to be a
welcoming Nation
a lot of conservatives in particular
would say that the rise in islamophobia
is a result not of hate but of fear a
legitimate fear they say of quote
unquote jihadist terrorism whether it's
Fort Hood or San Bernardino or the
recent truck attack in New York what do
you say to them
I would say uh our our country should be
more fearful
um of of of white men across our country
because they are actually
causing uh most of the deaths within
this country and so if fear was the the
driving force of of of policies to keep
America safe Americans safe inside of
this country we should be profiling
monitoring
um and uh and and creating policies to
fight the radicalization of white men
foreign foreign